the treatment of addiction that I am
familiar with is an attempt to address
the underlying cause that is normally
pain sense of ins low self-esteem
worthlessness all things like that but I
find this seems to be pretty common
among people outside of addiction as
well and actually the solutions that
recovery provide are effective for you
know for people that don't have an
explicit addiction because if you've had
that bulimia I'm sure all of us have
some sort of attachment something that
we're using to hold ourselves together
yeah and if you find something that
operates successfully within your
culture then you're all right you know
comedy stand-up comedy making money into
lately pursuit of conceptual consensual
sexual relationships all those kind of
things were like they're sanctioned but
it's only when you do stuff that [ __ ]
you up in an evident or criminal way
that is a problem in it okay so you
remove those things but you need to find
something to transfer that addiction to
I imagine yeah okay
you wake up if you will
is that is that fair to say it's exactly
100 accurate Andrew because the 12th
step of the system of recovery I believe
in
is having had a spiritual awakening as
the result of these steps is about
Awakening the suggestion being that you
are in some kind of stupa now that if
it's alcohol or drugs I suppose that's
obvious but we can all become Spellbound
through attachment we can all find
things to sort of hypnotize us yeah and
this Awakening is a yeah an Awakening to
the reality of who you are in both its
beauty but also in its trauma and its
flaws and what about an Awakening to
like what existence is yes I suppose
that would also be true but tell me how
we fit within existence I guess what I'm
trying to say is like I have certain
friends who have woken up if you will
and they got there because
they experienced some traumatic [ __ ]
maybe as a child or throughout their
life and they were incredibly depressed
and sad and then they distracted
themselves with drugs or addiction and
then realize that that drugs and
addiction just continued to make them
incredibly sad and they were forced
because it was either killing themselves
or finding a way to live within this
structure that we call life and there
were forts like analyze life in a
different way
and forced to like figure out what their
maybe purpose is or if there is even a
purpose but they were really forced into
being awakened yes and yes sometimes
those friends
have tons of empathy for people who
aren't awoken yet and sometimes they
don't my question to you is
do you see someone who's not awake yet
and go well maybe they don't need to
wake up maybe they're not suffering in
the way I was suffering that forced me
to go through what I had to go through
to wake up and figure out a way to
basically continue living because it was
death or this no we must still awaken
this is what I've learned from it I feel
like I'm lucky to have had the journey
that I had in terms of being a smack it
in a crackhead because those things are
extreme enough to Warrant intervention
at some point you have to stop it but I
think what we're dealing with now a
cultural modalities that keep us all
sort of loosely numbed and distracted
like I find it really hard to deal with
drug addicts when I have to deal with
them like it really bugs me and annoys
me sometimes maybe I'll like part of my
recovery is I have to and it's wise that
help others right help the others oh God
others not even them you're not actually
me sort of care and you're worried
you're still existing when I'm not there
and I've got to do stuff like so
on the streets lesion covered smack head
needle at the arm missing an eye oh I'm
all over them yeah oh I'm like Jesus
Jesus if it was a WWF version of Jesus
like I'm over there I may open a man
John not too close you know like giving
him everything that's required on that
yeah but like what about all people have
unconscious Tendencies if you're not
doing what you're doing consciously you
are likely doing it unconsciously
sometimes we don't know our motive and
what our motivations are all these
conflagrations inadvertent and
Irrelevant in even in the quotidians I'm
Skirmish in the street or in a parking
lot you know what is it really what is
it really when someone gets out their
car ready to kill you because you cut
them up in traffic first my whole
[ __ ] life and now this and now this
and like every single bit of pain you're
willing to express it all in that moment
so if you are awake you are able to
observe oh look I'm becoming anxious now
I'm afraid now if I come into a
situation like this like a sort of a
very mild environment you are all strong
gifted people I'm aware like I hope that
you know you've not bought me here to
[ __ ] me up and annihilate me that's why
I came in camouflage should it be
required I could just slink off like a
leopard but like a but like uh you know
like I'm stay conscious I stay conscious
and then I operate on these principles
if I in my heart I'm not trying to be
mean to anybody yeah I feel like I've
got a contract like so if I come in and
I'll start saying nasty [ __ ] then I feel
God's got my back if I'm behaving
properly that's what my life showed me
life has shown me I I asked that
question more because I find it like
when I'm interviewing somebody like you
who I obviously respect but more so than
that I don't feel like I can [ __ ]
you at all
so I'm very specific in the things that
I'm asking you because I feel like you
see [ __ ]
so sometimes [ __ ] is required for
social lubrication yes right so we do it
in life we're getting a [ __ ] coffee
this at the other but there are certain
people and you almost immediately upon
meeting you I was like okay there's
gonna be no room for [ __ ] right now
so I have to ask you the things that I'm
really curious about we have to tell you
the things that I'm genuinely curious
about even if I look dumb doing it or
maybe I look smart doesn't matter as
long as it's pure and authentic I think
it works yes you have to do that it's
necessary you obviously do it to a
degree naturally anyway otherwise you
wouldn't have been able to enjoy the
success you do either as in this format
or with the live stand up format what I
feel like like I'm what people do and
like you were kind enough to say about
when I went on them normal TV shows
where it's all graphics and glistening
it's like they think I like you're gonna
be an idiot because they think I'll let
you're a celebrity person but that's not
what I'm from that's not I was 30 before
I made any money out of this business
before that I was having to live in very
very different circumstances and I was
born in different circumstances and they
left my I mean I'm not trying to be ice
cube here I'm like from grazing Essex
it's sort of a bit like dull it's not
ice cube your idea of like the rough
life
like Ice Cube you know how rough it was
oh my God I was straight out of
competent I had to knit back I'd left
the gas on look in the Compton
put a few coins in the meter
Compton again no it's not like I'm
saying it's such a super street I'm
English I'm white all of those things
but what I'm saying is like there's a
degree of poverty and there's addiction
and all of those things and then having
to acknowledge like the amount of
personal failings and learning to deal
things like authenticity and integrity
are for me incontrovertible ideas I'm
still wrapped up and strapped up in all
manner of hopeless flaws and stuff but
what I do have now is I think um
presence I'm present yeah and I'm like
I'm I'm watching what's happening and
also you don't have to like you know
make excuses for your struggles just
because your weight like white people
have to deal with a lot yeah sometimes
the industry doesn't buy their special
you know
that's annoying every single day we
can't say anything about it so just five
dollars you can get Andrew some earplugs
so that you can block off the
complaining of the minority members who
is kindly put into this show so please
let him in the title it's not Andrew
Schultz is flagrant all sorts of people
here
two of whom are plainly not white and
even the one who is white has got a very
good natural hair lift thank you so much
that is true that is a good root lift
yeah it's incredible yeah it was in
Turkey I got it done it was amazing